so welcome to the demise conference this
lovely Thursday morning our chair bill
Hirsch never who usually does this is
unfortunately out of town so it's my
pleasure to introduce dr. Alan wolf who
it is from Loyola University and has a
PhD in genetics and a master's in
systems engineering from the University
of Arizona Arizona he postdoc with
Howard Berg at Caltech in Harvard in
1989 he started as an assistant
professor at Loyola University and he's
well known for his basic science work in
signal transduction as it relates to
central metabolism and about 12 years
ago he was introduced himself to your
Gynaecologists which really changed some
of his work and he will be talking today
about how he built the team that
overturned a dogma thanks Lisa so I I
have to disclose that I do get grant
money from a couple of companies but
does not have a whole lot of relevance
to the talk that I'm getting today so
since I decided to talk about team
building because I know that many of you
are are or going to be parts of
translational teams I thought I'd start
with the team so there are a lot of
names up here the blue is our people
that are have been in my lab if they're
bolded they're still in my lab and what
you'll notice is that so there these are
all basic scientists these are urology
residents an OBGYN OBGYN resident and an
MFM clinical fellow they sit side by
side with masters and
HD students and technicians and the
interaction is excellent for both sides
the the red are the leaders of groups
and the the bolded are individuals are
the ones that are the current leaders
one of the things you'll notice is that
the original leaders are no longer
leading and will make a point about that
a little later on and this asterisk here
is to point out that members of my group
have worked in the clinical microbiology
lab and so they interact they know how
to do clinical microbiology and that's
important because I'm actually running
and sort of under the table clinical
micro lab we don't report the clinicians
or the patients but we are doing
clinical microbiology for scientific
purposes and finally I'll mention Linda
Brubaker in a little while she and I she
was the era gynecologist I walked up to
and we built this team together and
she's now moved to UCSD and we still
collaborate we have escaped an hour
every week and is deeply involved in all
things work so science of teamwork I
stole this slide with permission from
Beth Miller who's now the clinical
co-director of lauric with myself and
it's it's from a Harvard Business Review
article by Hassan Mortensen so there's a
quote what matters most is not the
personalities attitudes or behavior
behavior styles of team members instead
what teams need to thrive or enabling
conditions and I will talk about that
you have to have a compelling Direction
strong structure supportive context and
a shared mindset I don't think I have to
convince you of that
so Beth put this slide together
basically asking so we do a dog-and-pony
show where we talk about what we thought
we knew about each other before we got
started and what we learned
like one of the things she found out is
that we're as clinicians when they go on
vacation they get coverage when basic
scientists go on vacation they get no
coverage which means that I wake up in
the morning I check to find out whether
or not there's a forest fire that just
blew up in my face and they have to deal
with it so that things don't get out of
control because there's no I mean I
trust my team but there are things that
happen and I don't get coverage and
there are other things that I learn it's
about the clinicians anyway the question
is you know is is thinks that one would
look about look to as output so are your
customers are happy with your output
your quality quantity delivery how does
your Team Dynamics help you work
together how collaborative are you
individual development are the team
members improving their knowledge and
their skills are you working towards a
compelling direction you have a common
goal that everybody is pulling towards
that it's clear it's challenging but as
it says here not impossible and
consequential so for NIH for example
that's what they mean about the mean by
significance strong structure do you
have the right number of mix of members
in terms of bandwidth and expertise are
your people responsible for the text the
tasks they're responsible for and do you
have clear norms for acceptable conduct
supportive context you have the
resources information and training that
we need and our people approach
appropriately awarded so reward usually
has to do with you know where you are
whether you're a co-author and where you
are on that or auto-ship with lists or
whether you get acknowledged in the
acknowledgments that's not necessarily
an easy
unpolitical problem to solve when your
worth dealing with teams and then
there's a shared mindset do your team
members have a common identity do they
readily share information with one
another and understand one another's
constraints so the clinicians and the
basic scientists grow up in very very
different cultures and I don't mean the
bacterial ones the reward systems are
really quite different as I was joking
with Tom I got a PhD I'd have to fill it
out a little bit I got a PhD so I could
wear jeans and lot of tie and get up at
a decent civilized hour and they got me
talking at 7:15 in the morning tomorrow
and okay so one of the other things like
I needed to tell you about this is that
about 12 years ago also I helped to
start an adult co-ed soccer club because
I wanted to play soccer and I'm ancient
and I had to play on a team that where
everybody knew their role because
running around like who can run the
fastest and banging than those people is
not what I'm capable of doing anymore so
I'm part of the senior leadership and we
try to bring new people in to help lead
we have three teams to try to lead these
teams and what we tell our people is is
that we do our job during the week then
everybody can show up on Sunday put on
their gear go out on the UNT's on the
field and play a soccer game such that
our team is doing more of this and a
whole lot less of that okay and the same
thing is true when you're building a
scientific team if the leadership works
together does their job and everybody
else can just come in and do their job
okay so I'm going to tell you my story
how I met Linda Brubaker how we built
the team the dogma how we overturned it
and then some of the things that we've
learned I am giving another seminar
tomorrow morning at 7:15 there is some
overlap but they'll be less of what I
just talked about and
more of the stuff at the end so if
you're interested in not being too bored
with what you already heard today and
you want to hear about a little bit more
of what we've learned come tomorrow
morning if you can get up that early
okay so I walked up to Linda because my
chair said you should meet this woman
she knew that I was looking for somebody
to work with on a clinical problem
because the work I was doing and still
do was very basic science of e.coli k12
the laboratory strain of e.coli and I
knew that it had an NIH shelf life of
about two weeks turns out that they're
still funding some of that work but I
needed something that had more of a
future and I'd been looking for the
right person and the right question to
collaborate on or with and on and so my
chair Katherine Knight who is an
immunologist the former president the
American in the logical Association in
any way she see it had co-chaired a
university committee with Linda bird
Baker and she told me I should go
introduce her so I did I walked up and I
said hi I'm Alan wolf we have two words
in common Ecoline I study it you want to
kill it and she said let's talk there's
a few more words in there we sat down
for a series of about 1 hour
conversations over the next several
months at one point she said you know
some people think that the bladder is
sterile and using a bunch of French
four-letter words I said no way because
I had studied bacterial motility in
chemotaxis and biofilms that I knew that
3 centimeters from the most one of the
most colonized parts of the female body
the vulva vaginal niche to the bladder
which is supposed to be sterile it's
three centimeters well that's a day trip
for e.coli and I couldn't see how in the
world that could be sterile and I said
if it is sterile
I want to patent it because something
special is happening now I've learned
that something special is happening in
the bladder because it is not nearly as
heavily populated with bacteria as the
vulva vaginal niche so there's something
immunological and antimicrobial going on
in the bladder that we are we definitely
need to understand so anyway the early
version of lauric was born it didn't
have this name right away and we we met
once a month we alternated sites she
came to my department I would come to
her department it was three or four or
five people sitting around a table
mostly just getting to know each other
understand the culture learning each
other's acronyms and jargon and mostly
we figured out that we had to DJ
argonauts
we had some very very funny
circumstances where the clinicians
thought they were getting sterile
samples because they were working in a
sterile operating theatre and that's not
the same thing as microbio
biological stability they asked well how
do you get microbiological Stewart
sterility and I said put a lid on it and
we were first horrified and then
laughing about it so we've had all sorts
of sort of miscommunications because we
use the same terms they don't
necessarily mean the same thing so you
have to get to know your team members
and you have to devote time to that and
DJ organizing is a great great idea
anyway we started with a 25,000 dollar
gift from a grateful patient who by the
way a couple years ago we donated more
money because of the fact that he turns
25 thousand dollars into many millions
of dollars and I can't compete for those
funds I'm not allowed to so it's for
other people trying to get something
like this up and running but we
bootstrapped we took twenty five
thousand dollars and turned that into
some internal funding which is about
thirty thousand and then we got some
money from her company and we got some
money from
NIH clinical trials Network and they got
some more money from them and then we
finally year several years down the road
got an NIH grant was an r21 which for
those who don't know it's a two-year
grant and then we turned that into a big
honor one which is half a million
dollars a year for desperately trying to
get refunded
so anyway Linda and I started with a
couple members of her prep practice I
had one technician so at the time I kept
saying that we have way too many chiefs
and not enough Indians and so I was
actually functioning of my own post on
mic technician was the only one that was
going to the bench and doing anything
and Linda was the one who were you know
going into epic and or into redcap and
trying to do that working it can't you
can't sustain that full focal vesser's
can't sustain that we're too long so we
needed to bring in more junior people
and we started to do that we recruited
Paul Shrek Umberger who is a director of
the clinical micro lab and that was
critical because as you'll see we
started out trying to identify bacterial
DNA using 16s ribosomal RNA sequencing
if that can't tell you whether or not
the bacteria alive and so we needed to
culture these organisms and I knew how
to culture a coli into Sylva subtlest
because those are the two bugs I've
worked on and now with all these
organisms some of which I recognized and
others like still can't pronounce and
Paul had that expertise and he had the
tools he got so that we could we could
eventually established and enhance
culture method that I'll talk about in a
few minutes um I've told this story a
couple times already since I've been
here came here yesterday
I went to I you and Bloomington to talk
to give a seminar on my basic science
and the last persons whose whose office
I was visiting with a guy by the name of
Dave Nelson who also was a bacterial
geneticist and
physiologists that he was had sort of
migrated towards microbiome research and
I had to stop them and say you need to
know about the other work that I'm doing
and I told him about our nascent
microbiome research which was basically
we know what we have to do we don't know
how to do it we had decided we had to do
next generation sequencing 16s
sequencing and I had no clue how to get
started and when I told him that he
turned around and started pounding away
on his computer and my initial response
was we'll jeez how rude could that big
and then he spun back around he said I
just sent you my grant proposal with all
my unpublished data then ultimately I
remember sitting in a Barnes & Noble and
I sent him in an email and asked how
much of this claim plagiarized
because I was trying to write an
internal grant to get some of that extra
money and said whatever you need so he
and Chungcheong dog who was he was
collaborating on as it's the bio
mathematician on their work our authors
on our first paper that showed DNA
evidence of bacteria in the bladder and
I owe a lot to them so instead of no
protecting his proprietary information
he shared and it was rather magnanimous
anyway it became clear that we needed to
have our own analytical team and our own
genomics and so we recruited Yahoo guy
who was a friend of Cheung Fong's as I
turned out as it turned out they
overlapped at I had at Iowa and he set
up a Center for biomedical informatics
at Loyola and wanted his own data so he
got them to buy him the DNA sequencer or
two and he set up the Loyola genomics
facility which I now direct and and the
way we went but what happened is is that
people moved on for one reason or
another so what I'm telling you is it at
the team that we that Linda and I build
and Paul though is robust because except
for Nene all the leadership is turned
over and it's running better than ever
Linda after a few years would be my
collaborator one day I woke up and she
was my boss's boss
she was now the Dean of the medical
school she lied to me and said that
nothing was going to change getting a
meeting with her was really hard but one
thing that didn't change and it's to her
credit is that our relationship didn't
change we were partners even though she
was my boss's boss and I had the
distinct pleasure of being able to tell
my Dean what her writing schedule was
how many can you can say that in any
case um after stepping down his Dean she
moved to San Diego and if not UCSD we
Skyped for an hour every week she's
still part of the team unfortunately
Paul went home after the party the
send-off party for Linda and and died my
team half my team he was there co-mentor
it was a very very hard day and a very
very hard week it was unexpected but he
had hired a young clinic clinical
microbiologist
to take over he was in phase retirement
so Amanda was already there and she's
still getting up to speed and and I meet
with her once a month so that she can
begin to integrate her ideas in telluric
so that we can take advantage of her
expertise and then Joe who got recruited
to Harvard so he and I got on the phone
called Chung plum and said would you
like to escape North Texas and he said
yes so he's now two floors above me and
then later on I met Catherine patanti
who is the director of the
bioinformatics program at our
undergraduate campus so she's got an
army of undergraduates mostly female and
a few masters students and that army is
fantastic it's a credible amount of
energy they very very good Catherines
teaching a graduate level fine
Mattox class that most of the graduate
students on my campus signed up for at
least in my department signed up for and
most of them dropped it because it's too
broad so I don't know what that says
about our graduate students versus her
undergraduates but my two students are
still in there and it's taken up a lot
of time and it's worth it even though
they're not as much at the bench this
semester because they're gonna learn
tremendous amount okay so how about the
direction well lower urinary tract
symptoms is a significant problem for
public health and for the individuals
that are afflicted it's not hard to
convince anybody that that urinary tract
infections and other types of what's
called a lot slower urinary tract
symptoms are significant problem but as
I'm going to show you the major
assumption about the bladder a major
assumption about the bladder is
incorrect and anytime you have a model
where a major assumption is incorrect I
can guarantee you the models wrong so
what does that mean everything we think
we know about the bladder has to be
reassessed I'm pretty sure the anatomy
isn't changing but what might what what
the microbiological environment and
therefore the immunological environment
have to be reassessed and since symptoms
and other organs are often associated
with microbes and and and the immune
system those symptoms the cause of those
symptoms or these contributions to those
symptoms has to be re-evaluated so I
think that's certainly enough it's
compelling enough for for our team so
here's the old dogma the bladder is
sterile back bacteria not involved in
most urinary disorders in fact urinate
tract infections well that's the other
way around
all the other lots besides urinary tract
infections our diagnosis of exclusion if
you don't if you're Colt urine culture
is negative for a typical euro pathogen
that's known to cause a urinary tract
infection that you don't have a UTI you
got something else and what you have
depends upon all the other symptoms
okay and urinary tract infections are
assumed to be an a sending invasion when
in fact they could be what we call a
dysbiosis that is a disruption of what's
normally there so our new discovery is
is the bladder and for that matter the
urethra have resident and distinct
microbiota that urinary disorders and we
some of them are caused likely caused by
dysbiosis and it's way more than we
thought okay so where did that that
dogma come from well it started back in
the very beginning of microbiology so
the early microbiologists one of the
things they were trying to disprove
right go back to your original biology
those who you had it is spontaneous
generation and so those those studies
that you read about where they put some
something in a flask and we've been
uncovered and some that same thing in a
flask and cover it and the thing that
was uncovered had got turbid or got
worms growing in it and the thing that
was left that was covered did not well
they did this with urine and they put it
in a closed flask and they left it in
open flask and the closed flash did not
grow anything crystal-clear okay right
there's the quote fresh and healthy
urine is perfectly free from back to
your other main new organisms and that
observation was made over and over and
over again
pick your favorite mic the early
microbiologist and they all said the
same thing in one form or another here's
the problem so although it's great for
disproving spontaneous generation the
problem is is that the organisms that
come out of the air and don't grow in
ambient atmospheric conditions at room
temperature or even at 37 degrees and
since and the bugs that did grow in the
open flask are the ones that fell out of
the sky
so they got the result they wanted but
for all the wrong places
so you know muscles you'll see most of
the bacteria bacterial species that
we've detected simply don't grow under
those conditions
he coli does okay now in the 1950s
there's a an ID doc infectious disease
done by the name of Ed Cass who was
trying to figure out a reasonably
non-invasive approach to determine
whether or not a kidney a kidney surgery
patient had pyelonephritis which is the
infection of the kidney usually usually
caused by e.coli and what he came up
with a protocol that worked really well
that is if they if they if you got a
voided urine sample
and there was more than a cannot if
there was a 10 to the 5 or more colony
forming units of per mil of a known your
pathogen thankee coli Proteus
Pseudomonas that person had
pyelonephritis anything below that was
what they call contamination the
argument that there's been a lot of
controversy over those thresholds should
it be 10 to the 5 or 10 to the 4 10 of 3
a 10 to the 2 whatever the problem is
it's all based on what's the standard
urine culture protocol they the standard
conditions vary a little bit from
clinical micro lab to amongst the
clinical micro labs across the the world
but generally they're a microliter of
urine on a couple of two or three
different types of plates at 35 degrees
in ambient atmospheric conditions for 24
hours and e-coli and Proteus and
Pseudomonas were under those conditions
and most other organisms in the bladder
don't okay so what happened is is that
people use this technique they migrated
it from China identified pyelonephritis
to try and identify cystitis which is an
infection of the bladder there is no
evidence that it works
and we've looked okay and so I don't
know how it migrated but it did and so
what happens is that the Quinn lab
technician will report no growth
well no growth means either there was
nothing on the plates or that something
grew on the plates but too many things
one of the plates so the assumptions are
no polymicrobial infections' which i
don't know how that got started but if
you see more than two organisms on a
plate you consider to be contamination
and if you see organisms that are
typical of skin or vagina
that's contamination too so what happens
is the clinicians get a report no growth
no growth no growth and they go oh the
bladder stone or Uranus stone and
medical students get taught that the
bladder and urine is supposed to be
sterile the graduate student who helped
Paul invent art enhanced quantitative
are expanded quantitative urine culture
or enhance method which I'll show you in
a moment was had something wrong she was
in the doctor's office she was in a lot
of pain barely conscious her mother had
been paying attention to her master's
degree and when the the physician's
assistant said the bladder has to that
bladder urine has to be sterile her
mother said no you don't understand
my daughter's the person who showed that
it's not I don't know whether that got
through to the to the PA or not but it's
a true story okay so this is the reason
we hypothesized the bladder wasn't
sterile first of all we knew about the
human microbiome we knew that we are
super organisms right it's us our DNA
and then all the DNA of all the
organisms and there's some debate as to
what the ratio is
it used to be dogma that it was ten to
one and now it's more like one to one
but you're walking talking incubators
and interacting with people it's a
really good way to give them your
microbes and when I tell the medical
students that I teach you get over it
we also knew that you know we can't live
with Adam they feed they protect us we
knew that other organs that have
originally been considered to be sterile
were not and we all and and and from my
micro microbiology background I knew
that most of them like most of the
bacteria don't grow understanding urine
cultures conditions so how did we test
our hypothesis well the first thing we
had to decide is how we're going to get
urine from the bladder and I discovered
that you can do something called a
suprapubic aspirin it horrified me when
I first heard about it but it is a
needle through the lower abdomen
directly in the bladder and you pull
urine out and then the process it it's
okay it's not people out on the street
being tackled and it's it's women that
we're going in for surgery and as far as
I can tell because I've been in the ER
once it's the least worst thing that's
gonna happen to them that day so we got
super pubic aspirants we had we had Sham
needle sticks so go in but not into the
bladder we had skin swabs from the place
where the needle needle went in we took
voided hearin vaginal swabs and we took
trans urethral catheterization with the
exception of one which we didn't which
we put aside to analyze separately were
in fact standard urine culture negative
and the question was could we detect
bacterial DNA in those culture negative
yarns and the answer of course is yes
how did we do this we used a culture
independent technique 16s ribosomal RNA
gene sequencing the 16s gene is present
in all bacteria it's part of the
ribosome or its meets the genes present
the RNA is part of the ribosome and
because the ribosome is essential for
life the 16s gene evolves slowly certain
parts don't evolve much of all and
others there are the constant regions
and others are variable but they very
slowly which means that you can use the
16s gene as a molecular chronometer and
if you can separate bacterial bacterial
taxa
on the basis of time then you can
separate them by species or at least
taxes so if you get the entire sequence
of 16s gene you can usually get species
level identification but the next
generation sequencing you give away a
lot of sequence information to get depth
so you sequence small regions the depth
is more important and and so generally
you can identify a bacterium to the
genus level sometimes the family level
so what we learned was that we could we
could in fact detect bacterial DNA of a
number of different genera in culture
negative urines we noticed that the
catheterized samples very often didn't
look like voided samples that is the
microbial profile the voided samples
looked like vaginal swab samples a lot
and the catheterized and aspirated
samples look very similar and they
didn't look like the other controls so
since the suprapubic aspirant bypasses
the vulva vaginal niche we could
conclude two things one is that we had
actually detected bacterial DNA take in
urine taken directly from the bladder
and that we could use trans urethral
catheterization as a less invasive way
to collect urine than a super pubic
aspirin so most of our sampling is done
by trans urethral catheter okay so the
next step was okay there's bacterial DNA
in these in these urine samples but are
those bacteria alive and so we I kept
pushing Paul can we grow these things
I'm looking at this the the general that
we can Kolb it that we could sequence
and I'm thinking I know you can grow
strapped and staffed and a number of
other organisms so why aren't they
growing understanding urine cultures
reproducibly
it's a distinction you will get
strapping staff and a bunch of other
organ into the grow but what we found is
that it's not
producible that is is very often you
miss it even though it's there so I
finally got Paul to come up with a
protocol that would that should grow
most of the organisms that we have
detected by sequencing and he called it
expanded quantitative hearing culture
and it's one of three different
published enhanced culture methods that
are out there okay so here's the
standard urine culture one microliter of
urine on blood agar macconkey agar and
they're really good for growing e.coli
McConkey is designed to detect e-coli
under aerobic conditions like just in a
regular old incubator for 24 hours of 35
degrees we use a hundred times more
urine a bunch of other different types
of media different types of atmospheric
conditions and we incubate it for twice
as long and what we found is that most
of the organisms that we could detect by
sequencing we can culture so I want to
give you an example now I'm gonna tell
you this is maybe the most extreme
example that we've ever seen which of
course is why we're going to use it as a
representative but this is blood auger
under atmospheric conditions for 24
hours typical this is the typical
standard urine culture approach and
there's nothing growing on that plate
now I'm going to show you 100
microliters ambient atmospheric
conditions 48 hours it's the same urine
sample that urine is not sterile and all
of that would have been missed by the
clinical microbiology technician no
fault of theirs it's the protocol okay
the 24-hour business whoops is the
reason why you wouldn't detect all these
little guys here there's plenty there
okay they would see them over here for
the 24 hours they didn't grow up okay
now I know that clinicians need to get a
report faster than 48 hours
but the point is is that many of the
urines that the standard urine culture
says no growth actually have bacteria
and the question is is who are those
bacteria are they good guys are the bad
guys and so on so what I want to do now
is talk about well now that you know
that there are bacteria in the bladder
what do you want to know about it okay
so the first thing we wanted to know is
well what bacteria are we detecting in
normal you know what's the normal flora
what's the normal microbiota and I'll
talk a little bit about each of these
topics as I move along for those of you
who may want to get up really early in
the morning and hear the talk tomorrow
I'll elaborate on some of the parts that
I write tomorrow but I'm not going to
talk about today because I spoke about
team building first
so what bacteria that we normally detect
and individuals that do not are not
currently experiencing lower urinary
symptoms they haven't taken antibiotics
recently so this is 200 over 200
controls so they are from a number of
different studies all women between the
ages of I believe about 25 and 80 who
don't have Luntz
and the black is those that are
culture-negative even by equal but what
you'll see is that and each of these
bars is an individual and we're only
representing I think every bit these are
I don't know how every 10 or something
like that
maybe less so each bar here like there's
a bar yeah that's one individual so you
can see the blue are some is these are
members of the genus lactobacillus and
that is always the most common dominant
member of the adult female bladder
microbiome second most common tends to
be guarding the rouler streptococcus and
then we see some staff and some ester
Ischia or Ecoline and then a whole bunch
of other things
okay so this is pretty typical the
sequencing and the culture they
complement each other they both have
biases they both out their strengths and
weaknesses they over there they report
their reports overlaps enough that we
know that their reader their accurately
reporting what they can report packs
loss who wrote the mother pipeline for
16s sequence analysis there's two major
ones mother and chyme he's responsible
for mother he claims that people should
not just do six in a sequencing they
have to verify the results typically
he's talking about doing qpcr but we do
culture something that some people are
calling mult meta cultural myths like to
go along with metagenomics so we're
doing that and we the overlap is
substantial yes
the controls are individuals the event
there there are individuals who do not
have Lauren or at lower urinary tract
symptoms so they're they're controls for
studies where we looked at other
different types of individuals of
different types of lower urinary tract
symptoms
don't have symptoms this is what we see
in people who nor we would not want to
say look it's an adult female and she's
healthy in terms of the lowering her
nature and that's what we see well no
some do indeed come up as negative now
about half of those will get positive
for sequencing okay so we can get
evidence of bacteria by one technique or
another in about 75% of controls no we
don't we're not arguing that the other
25% are sterile
did that just below the level of
detection I don't want to make an
argument about the absence of evidence
and what that actually means they might
be but they also may have fungi or
something else viruses that are in there
or bacteria that we're not detecting
okay so what are the organisms so the
cost we culture we've got 10,000
isolates in our freezers I tell people
I'm collecting freezers we're trying to
establish a urinary microbiome reference
collection so we took about 200 genomes
from about 85 different general from one
end of the diversity the phylogenetic
diversity of bacteria to the other and
sequence their genomes with the Sanger
Institute in the UK with though this is
triple mollies group and this year we
published this or this past year we
published this paper what I just want to
point out that of
all of these organisms they're almost
all gram positives the gram negatives is
this little tiny group here that's the
coal eyes Proteus Pseudomonas okay all
the rest are gram positives okay most of
the Europe the known Europe otha genes
are are gram negatives and antibiotics
work differently on gram negatives and
they go in gram positives so when you're
treating a gram negative infection you
may or may not be affecting the grand
positives which tend to be more of them
tend to be commensals
or healthy members of the
the microbiota or you may be killing off
one year a pathogen and making room for
a grand positive pathogen that you
didn't know is there okay so and I'm
pointing out that to a large extent on
creating more questions than providing
answers I do recognize that but that's
the first step
okay what about men so we took voided
urines and path yarns from men with
benign prostate enlargement and we found
that first of all but waited urine like
with women has more biomass than the
bladder which is a problem if you're
taking urine from the bladder and you
have to pass it through an environment
where there's more biomass you may in
fact if you're not careful be studying
the contamination and I've seen that
often in studies that I have to review
so what you can see is that there's only
a few here where they match up with a
voided urine microbe microbial profile
is different from in the voided year and
then in the calf catheter urine yes
there's a lot of men that are negative
but we do see bacteria in the cath urine
Candida is a yeast we'll never see that
by 16s sequencing because yeast have an
18 s gene no the 16s gene and there's
more difference between those two then
to us for those who understand what I
just said just looking at the time okay
so we rarely see lactobacillus in men
which makes some sense lactobacillus in
the pelvic floor is generally a female
thing okay so now um that's normal what
about the bacterial composition or
diversity of its associated with disease
so here's one study we did we asked is
there it's the bladder microbiome
related to lots and these were women
that were coming in for clinical care
that either had urgency urinary
incontinence
so that's overactive that's wet
overactive bladder versus those that did
not have lots so they would be part of
that control population I just put it
out we did equal and 16s sequencing on
them and I'm only going to show you a
little bit of the data but this is a
what we call a species accumulation
curve it's a rarefaction curve what
happens is that you know the first
person who comes in we ask how many
unique species are present and we count
them and then the next person come in
comes in did we identify a new species
and so what you're just simply looking
as you accumulate more and more members
of your cohort how many distinct species
of bacteria duty to detect attack or
what you're looking at a substitute the
trajectory and it's quite clear that the
cohort of women with new UI is richer
there are more species than then the
cohort of women that do not have you you
are in a quote unquote healthy we don't
use the term healthy because how do you
define how okay they don't have symptoms
they're asymptomatic yeah and these are
the organisms at the species level that
we detected is being significantly
different between the two cohorts so
first of all you'll notice that most of
these organisms you never heard of
before okay some that you might you know
certainly you might have heard of
corynebacterium here's gardnerella
vaginalis of course you know you've all
heard of lactobacillus I'm sure and
here's a streptococcus but most of these
are not the species that you're familiar
with in any case all of these were more
common in the symptomatic cohort than
the non symptomatic cohort with one
exception and that's lack of the sillas
course POTUS who was definitely a good
guy if I was a young if I was a newly
born female going up in getting in line
to get my vaginal micro and bladder
microbiome I would pick lactobacillus
course POTUS every time and twice on
Tuesday the other lactobacilli may or
may not be as good because you can see
that lactobacillus gasur I was that
acted more often in individuals with
symptoms but lactobacillus gasser is
considered to be a good member of the
vaginal microbiome okay and then there's
all these organisms that some of them
they're called emerging Europe athosian
so this is activity it's now called act
in or titanum shali i here's our caucus
urine a and these are organisms that me
or a former graduate student in my lab
that's not post docking at stanford are
trying to understand the physiology and
get them the genetics and try to
understand the organism itself because
no one's ever really studied them before
okay so here's a pie chart showing women
that are in the control group versus
those that have some form of urinary
incontinence versus UTI and mostly just
want you to see is that the urinary
incontinence group those pie charts look
pretty similar but they don't look
anything like controls and they don't
look very much like UTI and you can see
that well about half of the individuals
with with UTI are dominated by e-coli
but the other half aren't and so if
you're only looking at e.coli and
missing the other hand alright there's
another way to present this is a heat
map where the these groups are on the
bottom and I just want to point out that
the red these are the guys that are the
typical gram-negative your pathogens and
you can see that they're common in
individuals that fall into the UTI
cohort what's intriguing is that a
couple things is the rest of these guys
here the blue ones
these are gram positives and they're
amongst that emerging Europe atha gene
group one organism which I just
mentioned Eric caucus is common in
individuals with urgency urinary
incontinence but it's also common in
individuals that have UT is raised the
question are the people that you ui4
associate with Eric caucus actually
suffering from the earning track
infection caused by Eric caucus or are
the people who think we think have a UTI
actually at the dysbiosis that allows
Eric caucus the bloom
and it's really urgency urinary
incontinence and I don't know the answer
to that question but it's the question
that needs to be addressed
ok what about men with symptoms and I
just want to point out that that this
yellow line is shows you the level of
symptoms from not no symptoms or very
few symptoms up to very high symptoms
and you see more color on the right than
you do on the left so there's an
association with detection of bacteria
in the bladder by either ekwa or
sequencing in men with more symptoms and
there's a whole lot more green over here
than over on the right than on the left
that screen is always streptococcus in
our diagram black that was blue
gardnerella is maroon green is
streptococcus okay so what else have we
learned so we've learned that the
microbiota are distinct between you you
I and none you you I've shown you that
that they're distinct between urinary
tract infection and those individuals
who don't have urinary tract infection
we found that what I didn't show you
about that study that uui study is that
we found that individuals who responded
to an oral medication for fergus of
urinary incontinence for overactive
bladder those people had a very
different microbiome profile than the
ones that didn't respond okay so that's
first of all that means that you might
be able to predict who's going to
respond to it or not by taking a profile
phenotyping individuals prior to
treatment and the second is it's the
people who didn't respond probably don't
have the same problem as the people who
did respond and it's an anti muscarinic
receptor drunk
so they Tom we were talking about that
earlier these are often very
heterogeneous syndromes and maybe we're
starting to pick them apart we have
evidence that certain microbiota are
associated with a risk of UTI after
surgery and that there we've seen
bacteria associated with urinary stones
kidney stone
of all different chemistry's not just
the ones that are considered typically
to be what are called infectious stones
so what are the bacteria doing and
that's a story for another day in fact
all of us is gonna have to be a story
for another day see you guys and ask
questions do they different different
pelvic floor sites the answer is yes
here's just one thing the gut microbiome
is very very different from the the
vaginal and bladder microbiome who only
have some overlap so this is the reason
why we're establishing a sequence
database of urinary bladder isolates
because if you want to study the bladder
comparing your genomes to the same
species and isolated from the gut is
gonna give you a reneus information when
is the microbiome established we know we
know that children who are potty-trained
we can detect bacteria in their bladders
so we haven't gotten newborns yet we'd
love to get that but that's for the
future and then I just want to quickly
show you that the bacteria can change
over time in very interesting ways this
is part of a big study and it's over 90
days young women like yourselves
volunteer to sample themselves every day
you use a pair of your each we'll swab
as a negative control if they're voided
urine sample is distinct from the pair
of urethral sample then we can know when
they gave us that mythical clean catch
and midstream voided urine clean catch
if they're not distinct they're Springs
out of the study right if they are
distinct that we can tell if we're
getting a clean catch it may be because
they don't know how to do it or that
their microbiota are too similar okay so
without going into all the details my
student Travis lived in the bsl-2 room
for a year
and he collected information all sorts
of information from these women for a
lump for three months at a time he could
only do two or three women at a time and
I didn't see him for a you know pretty
sure that was true
okay the point here is is that many of
these women the parry urethra and voided
urine samples were distinct so we can do
it and here are four of those women and
you can see blue like the bacillus
maroon which is gardnerella the green is
strep the light blue is staff and the
orange is Killiney bacteria and here's
three more and if we go back to this one
these two up at the top what I'd say
what the what my soundbite is if I know
what your urinary microbiome looked like
last week and I know what it looks like
this week I can predict next week okay
with one exception and one thing I can't
do
I can't tell you what it look like
tomorrow there's too much dynamics we
think that some of the dynamics is due
to viruses that infect bacteria okay
they're called bacteria phage I had it
teach my clinician collaborators first
that bacteria had viruses and how you
pronounce stage or v shape you French
and so we're now doing managing omics
sequencing on these two individuals this
isn't I think it's this individual so
either this individual or that
individual yeah we're doing we're doing
metagenomic sequencing this is all
cultured data but we have the 16s data
as well here's what happens during
menstruation and you get a disruption in
this woman and over here and it's
reproducible you get orange more orange
and you get more Brown the brown is
actin oh my C's okay and and here is a
way of showing that these are the
organisms that are more present during
menstruation and these are the ones that
are not present or less present and the
thing is is there's your colony forming
units per mil so the absolute amount of
bacteria hasn't changed it's organisms
replacing each other and then the last
thing the last little bit of story I
wanted to show you is that Travis
noticed something really interesting
because his participants were reporting
on everything they did he knew when they
had sex and what kind of sex and whether
it was with one partner or several
partners and so what he found is that in
every case where spatula sex was
reported streptococcus showed up they
didn't sometimes it showed up other
under other circumstances you know you
can see this here but it didn't last
okay so what he's found is at the left
so this individual here he got her to
sign up again with her partner and he's
been he sampled them for a month before
and after sex they had to only have sex
once a week so he had enough time in
between he doesn't know the identity and
we go through you know the nurse
coordinator on this in any case and he
took oral swabs and skin swabs and stuff
like that because he wanted to know
where the strep is coming from and it's
plural but they're not necessarily
reporting oral sex of course I challenge
you to tell me whether you put your
hands in your mouth at any time when
you're having sex so we don't
necessarily we don't know in any case
we're sequencing the genomes of the
isolates yeah we're sequencing the
genomes the isolates to see whether or
not they are the identical okay and so
it turns out that and this is pretty
much hot off the presses
this woman's lactobacillus is of the
species Jensen he on lactobacillus
Jensen AI inhibits stuff dukakis well so
we think that she's getting a bolus of
streptococcus and it's knocking down the
lactobacillus gen Semyon and then the
gen sandy Ike that's left manages to
kill off the streptococcus and
reestablish itself as the dominant
organism now this woman doesn't get
urinary tract infections but he was
wondering whether or not if
lactobacillus inhibits the growth to
become
which is known to be the case and
perhaps what's going on is women that
are exposed to ecoli or other Europe
applicants get UTIs after sex which does
happen a lot from some individuals
because the protective microbiome has
been disturbed to dysbiosis
streptococcus doesn't inhibit ecoli
and if you're exposed to a your pathogen
you bloom that you're a pathogen and you
go off to the clinic to get an
antibiotic which may or may not be a
good thing to do so anyway we're still
working on that and these are some of
the questions that we're still trying to
answer when does it get established the
female urinary microbiome does the host
environment influence the thumb and vice
versa how do the members interact with
each other and with the yura theam and
the immune system which bugs are
protected which ones are pathogens what
mechanisms permit these bacteria to
reside in the bladder how do we
translate our discoveries into the
clinic we're studying stage I'm know how
many of you've heard of phage therapy
but we would like to be able to use
stage and probiotics and prebiotics
instead of giving antibiotics to someone
that has usually a self UTIs are usually
a self-limiting illness I know there can
be painful I've never had one but I get
it okay but there may be better ways we
can save antibiotics for those people
are going to die tomorrow if they don't
get them and with that here's my team
again I can't do it without them I'm the
figurehead and here's our mascot and
you're invited to ask questions
[Applause]
that's Travis's joke yes I want to
comment on the apparent lack of
diversity you see in individuals right
so you get dominance of one bugger or
another so I'm used to working in the
gut which is obviously a very poor
microbial community and I wondered how
that compared to what you'd see say on
the skin or elsewhere I thought those
were pretty funny microbial communities
as well and what about the bladder micro
environment might favor such a community
right so first I have to I have to make
the point that I'm showing you those
histograms are being shown genus so we
you may it's not quite as as underverse
as it looks but but you're right in
essence many individuals are there micro
biomes are very they're not diverse at
all in some cases they are simply
they're literally a monoculture I don't
know the answer to the question I don't
know what it is about the bladder that
that about some people's bladders that
supports the growth of the dominance by
one organism and not something that's
more diverse like the the oral cavity or
the vagina or the gut another point as
well and so again coming from the gut
field it was positive for a long time
that 90% of gut bacteria couldn't be
cultured right and looking at the
culture conditions you're using none of
these are particularly novel media's are
they I mean they've been around for
decades and but still just using those
very old media and couple of cultural
conditions in your eyes anyway you think
you can culture pretty much everything
like that was my impression if you
compare to your 16s yes you thought you
were able to culture everything they
wondered why
again I guess what you thought don't be
that difference perhaps between the gut
and the bladder okay so yeah there's
nothing terribly unique about ekwa it's
simply what is normally used on sputum
and blood and things but it's never
applied to urine because if you know
anything about clinical micro lab that's
what they do the most of it if they had
to do a click on every sample you'd
never get your report and and the
clinical microbiologists are kind of
horrified that we're going to end up
recommending they do a click on
everything which we won't do we the
organisms that we don't culture very
well until recently art and reproducibly
I mean we can detect them sometimes so
we were having some problem with
reproducibility of strict interrupts but
we now have an anaerobic chamber so
we're detecting them now they're
organisms that are very fastidious we
don't detect ylim idiot either by
sequencing or by culture Dave Nelson
does because he studies chlamydia that's
what got him into in the first place
we detect Canada in terms of yeast but
we haven't detected other other types of
yeasts and we don't detect detect fluffy
molds because we're not trying to and we
don't want to find fluffy molds because
will contaminate our lab and I'm sure
there's a handful of organisms that
we're not detecting that perhaps you
need you know they need a partner so
some of the organisms that were first
detected by sequencing that never been
culture before turned out then they you
can't you can't isolate them because
they're like you know they're they're
symbiont sites of another organism you
have to go and find the right conditions
but for the most part most of the
organisms that we sequence we can grow
well there any other questions yet Tom
less of a question is more of a sort of
comment just to suggest that one of the
things that you said the very beginning
of you talked about approaching Linda it
sort of struck me is I you know I as the
clinician in the room one of them you
know I'm always looking for partners and
I'm just as trepidatious about so just
reaching up to my my basic scientific or
translation of scientific partners and
so I welcome or we welcome the same sort
of thing from your standpoint so there
may be burning questions that we all
have that we just happened to meet in
the hall or in the room we'd be able to
conquer them yeah and as Linda Brubaker
says whenever she gets the opportunity
all hands on deck there's enough room I
tell my students we've we've landed on
Mars and it's not sterile and it'll be
four years before anybody gets up here
so what are we going to do to make it
possible for others to come up here and
help us it's a big planet there's a lot
you know there's room for everybody
so take up his offer
[Applause]